welcome to this video today you're one
of the more frequent opponents game 18
off this little match one draw only one
draw of 18 games this is quite good
ok we have them the London system and
quite a quite a decent line here for
black white can trade or go back in
after which Bishop f5 is quite nice to
have let's see yeah white who is going
for this quick move I think before is
right should before ok I want to I want
to provoke a three-year at least yeah
here maybe aged six is an interesting
IDM if he takes I can take with the pawn
maybe maybe then g5 is a threat and ok
so he was afraid of that but now I can
actually treat my bishop and it's not so
clear what when all this has
accomplished was night edge for not bad
for why do anything oh he tries to make
some sense out of it really interesting
it's a very risky decision though wait
wait wait just a moment it's their
Knight g4 maybe what is he playing on
not g4 there are various direct attacks
here
I'm just too curious yeah if he goes
Nydia three I have Knight takes III
maybe this is a very very valid option
Knight e3 Queen III Queen B - and this
gets very interesting
as f3 a sc3 as a tech and I have various
attacking ideas what you can't be
serious kingi to Bishop d3 check King f3
is this is this looks really strange
also I wonder if I take III is there
some sort of something going on it
really feels like or maybe if 5 here is
5
I wonder there are some weird things
possible here in this position I'm
pretty sure I also have this idea 83-93
but it's not working right
takes 93 King is free 94
CD Queen takes King takes Bishop c5
check it's not working it's really not
working but now I can give this check
here you cannot go to f3 angle just take
III here right
gathers ff4 was a really weird idea now
I can go to c2 actually and then take on
d4 I have this is this is flat-out
winning I think you know this is winning
it's just this is just too much this all
this discoveries and you cannot take it
takes King King needs to go to f3 and
there should be some sort of punishment
for that and the rook is hanging all the
time so just just to take first and
check ask questions later this check
here King d1 mmm I wonder if I should go
c3 first actually or the check and then
c3 c3 first maybe hope to do we should
be form
hmm I'm not sure
see three maybe really see three first
ship takes Queen takes yeah again it
really should be truly should be
convincing them or take what is first
many I can also take here
Queen takes and Bishop before this kind
of idea yeah that's that's actually the
check the easiest thing of all just win
the Queen here check first I guess check
and then then grab the Queen and I can
still castle here should have to I can
take F form
so I'm let's let's count this I'm a
queen queen for something it's just a
couple of points in the exchange I'm
learning Czech still still enough of
course but it's not like a bunch of
pieces okay maybe the F pawn for f3
quickly advancing to attack his some
backing
once you exchange the bishop in
my queen age three will be a big problem
Queen age 3 a 2 G - they were just check
just the pawn
check-check
I really wants to do something on the 20
seconds here
check check check check
13 seconds is plenty Roger white resigns
yeah this was very weird opening game
yeah this F for business yeah I don't
know when I G for looks very tempting so
I went for that and I thought that this
and 93 could be good the computer just
plays Bishop e7 here intending 28
probably or something or g5 even I was
thinking that this was interesting
maybe not correct but interesting and
here okay rook do you want I don't have
a direct what I was thinking actually
what is that I thought I have this
smooth but the computer points out Queen
d2 which seems to defend this in fact is
check is very interesting I mean I just
thought that okay this could be
something other C pawn yeah maybe c3
even the Bishop b5 check is good and
wins actually okay yeah I thought this
is interesting the computer actually
gives black and clear and share with
with taking and then castling but it's
not forced he can play the smooth and
defend yeah weird this was my idea and
then he played this smooth but g5 is
just wrong okay g5 I understand just a
text this and while he cannot yeah I
probably must go back and then I have
this check and take we should be sixes
even stronger according to the computer
but okay he went I went with rooks e8 I
was I was actually fascinated he played
this I was actually fascinated by this
idea taking
then then possibly take here but this is
totally incorrect this this is what I
had seen just to just to show and then
then f6 should be made somehow yeah it
is a mate King e7 intending f6 checkmate
its I only had seen the idea and this
this would be a made ready computer give
some made but this is of course total
bogus because he can go here I had just
this idea with the Queen this is why
would I wanted Bishop Bishop c5 this is
why I played rook c8 but okay it wasn't
working and here well this was a simple
a simple solution probably I made life
too complicated but you can hear Bishop
b4 as simple and good but this is also
when you check yeah yeah okay this is
just a win he just played on on a while
because of my sword' no time okay thanks
for watching